una luz de esperanza para el control de
armas en eeuu la cámara de
representantes aprobó un proyecto de ley
que elevaría la edad mínima para la
compra de armas semiautomáticas a 21
años
en esta votación los 10 son 223 dos no
son 204 el proyecto de ley se aprueba
sin objeciones se pone sobre la mesa una
moción de reconsideración es weibo
la ley también endurecería las
prohibiciones sobre las armas no
rastreables los republicanos en la
cámara están en desacuerdo con el
proyecto y lo que hace este proyecto de
ley es quitar los derechos de la segunda
enmienda de derechos dados por dios y
protegidos por nuestra constitución a
los ciudadanos estadounidenses
respetuosos de la ley eso es lo que hace
esta legislación y por eso debemos
oponernos a él
si el proyecto con la oposición
republicana podría ser frenado en el
senado aunque los demócratas en cabeza
del líder jackson avanzan en las
negociaciones en una manifestación entre
armas en washington el senador se fue
directamente contra la asociación
nacional del rifle
sabemos del control que tiene la nba
sobre los republicanos pero le decimos a
la nba salgan de nuestro camino
los demócratas tras el tiroteo de ubal
de donde murieron 21 personas entre
ellos 19 niños buscan a toda costa que
se aprueben restricciones en el pasado
ya han intentado que se adopte una
amplia legislación de control de armas
para frenar oleada de asesinatos en masa
que este año en eeuu ya han superado los